I'm a therapist whose job it is to help
people create healthier relationships
and let me tell you it can be really
hard to tell someone what you need it
takes a lot of courage to stand up and
say this is the way I want to be treated
most of us aren't so great at vocalizing
to the people in our lives what makes us
feel respected and valued is true with
friends family partners and it's also
true at work you gotta set healthy
boundaries
bye
boundaries can be an intimidating term
but they're very simply the expectations
and needs to help us feel safe and
comfortable in relationships work is the
relationship we spend the most time in
and yet it's also the place where we
have the hardest time setting limits
we're scared that people won't see us as
a team player our employers have
boundaries built in like the time your
work day begins and how many vacation
days you can have but work boundaries
need to be a two-way street boundaries
for your employer and boundaries for you
setting them can help you feel happier
and more fulfilled in your roles not to
mention less exhausted and overwhelmed
at work we often assume that other
people have the same rules for life as
we do we think they can tell our
preferences and know our feelings from
our body language but no one not half of
people you've known for years and
certainly not your co-workers can read
your mind you have to explicitly State
what you need communicating what works
for us is one of the kindest things we
can do the short term discomfort is so
worth it for the long-term ease of
having healthier boundaries in the
workplace here are three steps to help
you get started step one identify the
boundaries you need to set there are so
many different kinds for example you can
tell a colleague what hours you are and
aren't available to work you can share
that you need to leave the office
promptly at five to pick up your
children or that you log off fully on
the weekends to really recharge you can
tell them how you prefer to communicate
that you enjoy talking by phone rather
than instant messaging or texting
especially with your bosses you can and
set boundaries around how you like
feedback you can say I work best with
clear deadlines can you please set one
or you can tell them you like written
notes on your work so you have time to
digest the feedback you can set
boundaries on how you interact with
people socially for example it makes me
feel uncomfortable when you share gossip
at my desk or no I'm not interested in
drinks after work but I love to go to a
yoga class with you you can even set
boundaries around your calendar and ask
that people ask you before throwing a
meeting on it as you prefer to be aware
of what your day looks like step two
think about how and when to make the
statement boundaries are like classroom
rules you want to set them as early as
possible people do it all the time in
the job seeking process they may say
something like I have vacation planned
for these dates will I be be able to
take my vacation if we can go into a new
work environment and with people already
knowing what we can and can't do that's
a beautiful way to show up if that feels
like too much orientation can be a great
time to set boundaries when your
supervisor tells you the work day ends
at six just flow it in that's perfect I
need to leave work at six one boundary I
want you to set right away is to take
every single day of paid vacation you've
earned it you need the rest and
recharging is good for work-life balance
and by the way it's perfectly acceptable
to set boundaries for yourself when you
notice something in the work day isn't
making you feel good so if you get a
headache when you have five meetings in
a day tell yourself that four will be
your maximum if you get anxious trying
to respond to 200 emails on Monday
morning Don don't do that first thing
break it up in half hour increments
throughout the day I have a set of
boundaries around my work for me I like
working in 30 minute chunks I don't like
answering every email as soon as I get
it I like sitting with the information
before I respond you have to set emotion
those new habits and practices that will
make you feel at ease and now comes the
most important part of the process step
three you have to stick to the
boundaries you set if you say you're not
available after six don't respond to the
group chat if you say you're not
available on weekends don't be available
on weekends when you respond to emails
or agree to look at that proposal out of
those bounds you're teaching people that
the boundary isn't real that it's okay
to violate it consistency is really key
here that might mean restating the
boundary more than once that might mean
reminding yourself why you set the
boundary in the first place setting
boundaries is hard at first but the more
you do it the easier it gets boundaries
are contagious once you start to
consistently Implement them others will
too you might be the inspiration that
helps them set better boundaries even if
they don't have the courage right now
it's now in the back of their mind